all right guys
bang bang i have diogo here with me
thank you so much for doing this sir
thank you so much for having me all
right let's jump right into your
background what did you do before
anchorage
yeah so maybe we can start 15 years ago
my uh
my career started in the academic realm
so i did a bachelor's and master's and a
phd
in computer science funny enough 12
years ago i was publishing academic
papers
and things like hash cash and byzantine
for tolerance you know before it was
cool and definitely not applied to
monetary policy
uh but you know academic research that i
thought it was absolutely useless
alongside my phd absolutely useless but
it turns out that 12 years later there's
some modical amount of utility here
uh and so then in 2011 early 2011
a company called square flew me out of
lisbon into
uh into the u.s to san francisco i
remember that i
landed on a sunday night at 11 p.m eight
a.m monday morning i was working
so it was a very very fast transition
and i was very early employee at square
uh cool claim to fame there is that i
actually have the patent on the little
encrypted credit card reader
i'm sure you've swiped your credit card
on and also that it was square the same
week
uh nathan and i my now co-founder and
the person that i've been you know
alongside for the past 10 years we met
at square the same week so that's
actually kind of the beginning of the
story of anchorage
is that first week at square and so
leading the platform security team at
square
and then after uh four years nathan and
i moved together to a company called
docker where we led the security team
there
and then uh three years ago we started
anchorage so that's kind of like the
short version summary of uh how we got
here so
you have the patent for the actual
physical reader
that square uses that's right the
encrypted version of the reader uh both
nathan and i
are on that pattern and you know at this
point there's a lot of different readers
and a lot of different variations but i
still think it's actually pretty cool
yeah that's awesome and so when you guys
left docker talk to me about what was
the impetus to go start anchorage
kind of why did you guys want to go do
this yeah what happened was
i would say the universe handed us in a
silver platter
the one business that we're uniquely
qualified for
if you think about the background you
know academic experience and distributed
systems
financial experience in payments you
know moving up hundreds of billion
dollars of payments
and then infrastructure security at
docker and the venn diagram is literally
private keys that are worth hundreds of
billions of dollars that's it that's the
only thing that i'm qualified to do
is to protect private keys that are
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
and so what happened was uh people
realized that and started reaching out
to me
in uh early 2017 when you know the
prices were booming at the time
and the first client that reached out
just for consulting
had lost the passphrase to a 10 million
bitcoin wallet
and it was offering me 20 if i could
break into it so that was just the
introduction to the business
and the introduction to how hard it is
to actually uh do custody
and so that one thing led to another
more consulting gig start coming in
until i really didn't have time and
today uh
to to to deal with all of this and
nathan and i had been working together
for seven years we were the perfect team
with a perfect background to start this
and so that's kind of how the
original idea came to be was from out of
clients need
when somebody calls you and says that 10
million i'll give you 20 if you can get
in do you say yes i'll try
oh yeah absolutely you do absolutely you
do especially when you realize that it's
going to be a lot easier
than you thought it was going to be
because they actually have the seed
the seed has just been generated in an
old version of the software and they do
not know how to get the old
version of the software together to
actually recompute the private key and
if it's that easy you absolutely say yes
and that's literally what it was that's
literally what it was there was no need
to attempt to brute force the key
or any kind of fancy you know kind of
like nothing fancy it was just
minimum competence but it really speaks
to you know you know number one
how hard this is to to do right and
number two how
even the easy stuff is easy to screw up
and i think that's actually pretty clear
because we've seen
three years ago there were no
institutional custodians platforms in
the space
and now uh in three years ago
self-custody was very common
and running rampant and a lot of people
are having issues and now that's you
know it's long gone
self custody is no longer really a
relevant part uh people
are trusting custodians like ourselves
and platforms like ourselves like
anchorage to actually
do these services and so it's been a
dramatic shift over the past three years
absolutely and so talk a little bit
about when you went from the consulting
gig to actually building anchorage what
was the original product was it just hey
we're going to go protect private keys
or kind of how did you guys think about
the business and the product
yeah the immediate needs were very clear
people
wanted to protect private keys for a
whole slew of assets
not just bitcoin at the time if you
remember it was kind of the beginning of
the ico boom so it was a whole slew of
assets
ethereum was very much much a thing at
the time and
people wanted to have a safe place to
store it but we also had
very very large crypto funds
venture capital firms some of which were
registered investor advisors and needed
third-party custodians to actually host
them
so it was very obvious to us that going
the qualified custodian route
a regulated platform to store these
assets was actually the right path and
that's what actually started anchorage
so now anchorage is very much a
regulated
digital asset platform and we can call
ourselves a platform
because we provide both the services and
the infrastructure
that institutions need to participate in
the space and i really mean all the
infrastructure and all the services
it's not just custody it is trading it
is financing
borrowing and lending it is staking it
is governance participation it is defy
integration and yield generation it is
all of these different things that you
can now do with these assets which are
really exciting
and you can do then and that we allow
you to do in a regulated
safe manner insured and you know all the
bells and whistles that institutions are
expecting
what's really interesting to me is uh
most of the early businesses in crypto
they really focused on brokerage models
right kind of the exchange businesses
and those are fantastic businesses to be
in they can be highly profitable
and kind of there's you know pick your
example that you want to look at across
the world
but what we know from the traditional
finance world is the companies that
focus on deposits and payments
tend to actually have much more scalable
business models they can grow to be much
bigger right
i always use actually the example of the
difference between like a robin hood and
a square when i when i talk about this
framework you having worked at square
uh makes it even better but it's kind of
like robin hood's uh
ability to go into other types of
financial services
is actually much more difficult than
square which starts out with the
deposits and payments and can quickly
add
brokerage crypto all these other things
and so it sounds like you've almost
basically
replicated that again with anchorage
where hey you go ahead and deposit we
protect your your deposit or your assets
um in those private keys and we
basically give you all sorts of
functionality and financial services
around it
that you can then basically put to work
these digital assets that you have with
us right
yeah absolutely actually so let's use
that comparison let's look at the
traditional prime brokerage stack right
you you do have custody in the
traditional prime brokerage stack and
you have custody services administration
services
and then you obviously have brokerage
you have securities lending
you have capital introduction we have
all these services but one thing that
you note
that is fundamentally different between
crypto and traditional world is the fact
that
in the traditional world all of those
building blocks
are independent you can come at them in
any there are people that primarily do
cap intro there are permanently
people that primarily focus on trading
there are people that primarily are
custodians
so you can come at it in any kind of
angle in crypto the interesting thing
that happens is that
every single service is dependent on one
thing
which is you have to have custody you
need private key custody if you do not
have the internal competence of private
key custody you can do lending you can
do trading you can do settlement
you can to you can actually keep even
the collateral if you're just a borrower
and so what has been happening is
there's definitely been and i'm sure
you've seen this
uh vertical integration of custody into
everybody's stack it doesn't matter
where you start with
if you start as an exchange you now have
a custody product or you partnered or
you bought
if you started by doing lending now you
have a custody service that you're
trying to add
if you started by you know just doing a
best execution service you realize
quickly that you actually have to own
some portion of the stack so custody
really is the building block
that is in common with all of these
other uh
services in in stacked and that's why
we're so excited because we really have
the best platform the best technology
and it's battle tested
uh over the past three years and we've
built already built all these services
on top of it so our approach was always
you have to do the hard thing first and
the hard thing
is how do you have better security than
code storage
without the trade-offs without the
humans going around and doing things
how can you get better synchronical
storage without sacrificing time
as the trade-off so that's what we've
done and so
you now have uh much much larger
aspirations but before we get to those
larger aspirations let's talk about just
who's using the product right so what
are the types of customers i don't want
any names but just
um that you see either coming inbound or
you guys reach out and end up going
ahead and choosing to work with you guys
are these
um large asset managers are these just
wealthy individuals is it a mix
how do you break down your customers
yeah three years ago it was primarily
crypto funds and vc firms that was very
obvious people
investing in these assets and you know
the goal was an investment the goal was
obviously to have these assets
appreciate and betting on these
protocols now
it's a completely different story we
have clients everywhere from still
crypto funds so some of the largest
crypto funds
think folks like paradigm polychain a16d
crypto
all the way to very large institutions
like visa
so it really ranges the gamut and what
we've seen in the market is that there's
a lot more types of clients that didn't
exist before
so now miners are clients that are very
exciting and it's not just
bitcoin mining you also have falcon
mining you also have the protocols
themselves
anchorage has the protocols treasuries
so people
actually leave the assets with
encourager protocols themselves when
they're
when they're launching a new project
they want to keep the treasury with the
platform that gives them all these types
of services the financing the custody
the apis and so they use it so protocols
is a big big
portion of client based recruitment
large institutional
asset managers traders active traders
that use our trading apis
think about all of these different types
of client types that are just coming to
the space that are really filling the
edges
so now it's very much moved away from
the traditional crypto fund nvc firm
and i would say that the majority of the
growth is elsewhere
in fact one of the things that is worth
pointing out is that one of the highest
highest growth areas that we've seen
this year has been the banks
the occ clarity that came from ucc
around
national banks being able to work as
custodians for digital assets and the
backing for
stable stable currencies has just
created a boom
the clarity just made all of the banks
come to us
and want to partner because everybody's
seen post paypal post square
that they want to offer these services
to their clients too and so all of a
sudden
that type of client which was in
existence three years ago
it is now you know one of the one of the
places where we're spending the most
time on
talk a little bit about uh when you walk
in i'm assuming that there's a
conversation around technology
and then what i'll call kind of career
risk mitigation right so on from a
technology standpoint
um i can't think of a better group in
terms of of that custody and kind of
your guys background and understand the
technology and the people you serve etc
uh but your name is not fidelity or
state street or you know kind of one of
these
um custody providers or custodians from
the the legacy world
um the institutional world for those who
don't know is highly highly conservative
and a lot of times there is this
mentality of like you don't get fired
for going with ibm or with state street
et cetera
how have you kind of navigated that been
able to convince people that
anchorage is the best solution in the
marketplace
even though you are relatively young
compared to you know something has been
around for 100 years
yeah i think one of them is show our
work and the way that we show our work
is
if you get a demo of our platform and if
you see if you see our systems operating
you immediately get a sense of you
understand
that the quality that you're seeing
reflects itself throughout the whole
stack
you really you feel when you're getting
a dim of the product and when you're
seeing anchorage that this is the safest
platform
they have thought about so much so much
more than any single other player in the
market in terms of
expanding the attacker model and being
very considerate about what they're
actually doing
in thinking about the usability and
thinking about the use cases of
institutions
that everything else must be at that
level of quality
so that was an immediate thing for us is
like the product really speaks for
itself
and then what we have is we all
obviously have proxies now three years
later
for that type of competence we have a
sock one we have
insurance by aeon we have
lending licenses we have a qualified
custodian as a trust chartered south
dakota company
and so we have all of these check boxes
that people are looking for
let's look at anchorage as a company
sakuan check
insured check qualified custodian check
all of a sudden the people that are just
you know
nobody has got ever gotten fired for
hiring ibm nobody's ever gotten fired
for like following this checklist and
saying oh no this company is perfect on
all these aspects and by the way look at
the product
it really is self-evident and also at
this point we really have a
humongous track record you know we are a
top platform
there's very few other people that are
even at the same level in terms of
assets under custody in terms of assets
transferred on the platform in terms of
services
offered people see a safe counter party
that has all of the services that they
want they see a one-stop shop they no
longer see
they no longer see the need of them
going and picking out all of these other
services and so that really drives
people towards anchorage
and then finally what i would say is the
brands that use us are the most
technically sophisticated brands
as i mentioned um if you if you really
care about crypto and if you know
who the right who the right clients are
a rolodex of clients really speaks for
itself
and so nobody ever got fired for using
the same custodian as visa
is also something that uh that you can
say i love that
uh let's talk about uh the recent news
which is that you guys filed for a
national bank charter
uh i don't think that people were
supposed to figure this out or find
out because i don't think you guys
announced it um but kind of what can you
say there and and maybe explain some of
the thought process behind filing for
that charter
yeah that's um it definitely got leaked
um because all of these are publicly
um publicly announced and posted on the
website um on the occ website
i think it's really exciting it is
really exciting not only the occ
letters provided guidance around what
national banks can do the fact that
anchorage
uh might be the first federally
chartered national bank to provide
crypto service and being crypto native
that really is a huge step for for the
space so i think for us there's a lot of
advantages in having that charter
around preemption of mtls and expansion
of potential business lines
but really about the fact that right now
in 2020 20 all the banks are coming to
us
and it becomes a lot easier for you to
do business when the bank when you're a
bank yourself
and when you're actually also a national
bank and so the the regulation is the
same and so it just removes a whole swat
of conversation and questions
that used to appear so it furthers what
i've been saying around you know
the proof is in the pudding and
anchorage is already done all of the
things to prove itself as a very big
player in the space this is just another
step
it's helping the space it's helping
everyone not just anchorage and is
really showing a path forward
to have something that is better um more
clear
from a national bank perspective around
partnering so that's that's something
that we're really excited about and you
definitely will see more news about it
very soon absolutely and it feels like
every bank of financial service now has
to have a
bitcoin or crypto strategy right paypal
square
like there's just too many players that
come from like a fintech perspective
that are large
that it feels like now the hand is
forced and every single financial
institution has to have that is that
what you're seeing as well
that's exactly what we're seeing we're
seeing two distinct things though i
would separate it between bulge brackets
and how they're coming into the space
and what they're asking for
and the neo banks or the challenger
banks so to speak the challenger banks
are very much coming to the space and
saying
hey i want to connect with millennials
in gen x and i know i can do that
through crypto
paypal square is doing it i want to do
it too anchorage
can you help us do this and we're like
yes we have all the apis we have all the
services all the regulation you can do
that tomorrow
so that's one big uh
driver of growth for us is the
challenger banks and the new banks
the other is the bulge bracket banks
which are very very interesting but a
lot of the
bulge bracket banks and of course this
is not like you know a perfect mapping
but a lot of them are coming to space
and saying
hey i actually want to provide these
services to my
to my clients and i want a sub-custodian
partnership can you do this for me which
is slightly different than what the
challenger banks are coming from
also the bulge bracket banks are a lot
more interested in things like
issuance of stable civil currencies
and trying to own that or they're a lot
more interested in
lending and how they can actually expend
that um that business line for them
and how they can actually use bitcoin as
collateral for fiat loans
so all those services of anchorage that
we already have so we already have a
silvergate partnership
where silvergate is capital provider and
anchorage does
risk management automatic liquidation of
collateral we keep the bitcoin
collateral under custody
within the same platform again like
integrated platform for everything
you can just click a button on the
anchorage platform and borrow fiat
into your account we're integrated into
sen and that appears into your account
basically immediately
so it's a pretty cool experience very
usable and it is
fiat loans backed by bitcoin collateral
some of the bold racket banks are
looking at this and saying oh this is
actually a fantastic business
we want to get into that who has this
already available and then anchorage
becomes the obvious place
of proven custodian proven platform
already has this
up and running already has clients for
all these services so they just want to
come in and partner
so yes they're coming in and depending
on who they are they're coming in for
slightly different sets of services
what's been the most surprising thing
when you talk to kind of legacy
financial players is it what they're
asking for is it maybe what they're not
asking about
like what just what's been some
surprises in those conversations
well what has not been a surprise has
been the extent of the rfis and the rfps
and the very very large number of
questions that you have to answer every
time you participate that has not been a
surprise at all
very much expected and it's i can tell
you it's there it very much is there
um what's been surprising i think it's
been the sophistication
and some of the banks coming with very
specific
businesses in mind they want to do this
one thing they don't
just want to have a crypto strategy
anymore or a blockchain initiative
where they they want to partner with
with anchorage because they want to say
they have a blockchain strategy it is no
longer that
that was the case two years ago three
years ago and before that was very much
the case where people were just
investigating and trying to see what the
space was all about right now they're
coming with very specific services and
saying hey i want to provide this
service
how do you anchorage make it easier for
me to provide the service safely
and so that's the answer and so the rfis
and the rfps are a lot more targeted
and that's really amazing to see because
it really speaks to a cohesive strategy
on their side
and the fact that they've already went
through the homework they're already
highly educated in the space they
understand exactly what they want and
they're coming to the right set of
players that are they identified in the
market and they're trying to partner
with them to get something tangible
out they have deadlines they have goals
and so it really is becoming part of the
business machine
and the business money making operation
machine which is amazing
because these banks really only move if
there's an actual business behind it and
now there's a business behind it
it's incredible to kind of watch this
happen so quickly
talk a little bit about how price
impacts uh the
interest level coming from them i'm
assuming as they see price go up
uh they are saying wait maybe we should
be doing this on a faster timeline
uh or you know this was going to be a
second half next year exercise maybe we
need to
kind of move it up um in our priority
list what what are you seeing there
uh related to price yeah that's a it's a
hard one it
two years ago in the last or three years
ago when we when we had the last run-up
of bitcoin and bitcoin was over 17 000
or 18 000
um the last time around what we saw
was exactly that it was fomo of missing
out on crypto and missing out on the
price action and this is a thing
but it felt like they were interested
without having done the homework and
understanding really what it was
this time is actually fundamentally
different it might be that it's
accelerating their roadmap but they
already had a roadmap they already had
the goal of doing this
in maybe late 2020 maybe early 2021
maybe
late 2021 and they're just trying to
compress the roadmaps a little bit
so it's actually funny because i don't
see a lot of people just jumping into it
because of fomo this time around
i just see them hey this proves our
point like it just increases the
priority of the project internally
at our institution more than now this is
the thing that we need to do that we
weren't doing before
so i think that's actually fundamentally
different from three years ago
yeah that's really interesting and then
i guess the other big difference is
covid uh which is probably
uh impacting you guys internally and
also externally how has that played out
i think the biggest impact is the one
that has happened to everyone which is
closing down offices especially for
anchorage we have one of the things that
i'm the most proud of
is really the company culture and the
culture is just
amazing and that company culture was
built primarily in person right
in office and so i i i think that we
have an amazing culture
right now and the question now becomes
can we keep that up can we keep that up
in a world where offices are not as
important
and are not going to have as much of a
focus so that's definitely been the
hardest thing for us
but otherwise i will actually point out
that the pandemic has been
very beneficial to crypto and
specifically very beneficial to
anchorage
and i'll give you a couple of reasons as
to why the first one
is the competition in the space in terms
of technology
for safe keeping of assets and for asset
platform
is still primarily called storage that's
what other people are offering
and cold storage relies on humans and if
humans can go to offices into banks
how do they actually transact crypto and
the answer is they don't
and so there were a lot of issues with a
lot of clients that came to anchorage
because we have something safer
but accessible so once everybody went
remote our transaction times and our
actual customer customer times
transactions
assets entering and leaving the platform
actually reduced
the withdrawals were faster overall and
so really being in an office do not
impact at all because we don't have
human operations when it comes to
securely and safely
dealing with crypto assets we have built
something that is better and so
that was actually an advantage to us not
as his advantage uh
kovid shutting down everybody else's
offices and banks and
needs to bring humans making making it
harder to bring humans together to do
key signing et cetera et cetera all
those parties all ceremonies that you
need to do
for cold storage that actually improved
anchorage's service comparatively with
everybody else
it brought to light oh wow this is
really a way better way of doing the
platform
and why were we doing pirate custody in
the first place right bearing these keys
in islands and putting them in treasure
chest in the first place this makes no
sense
that we have digital assets and then
we're doing the same that they did in
the 1700s
so that was something that was very
beneficial for for anchorage there
and the the other side is obviously i
think the capital preservation
capital preservation narrative that
we're seeing in publicly traded
companies like microstrategy and square
so on and so forth has also benefited us
quite significantly because it expanded
the addressable market
the addressable market is well is larger
it was not
like publicly traded companies and
treasuries were not part of our
addressable market a year and a half ago
or a year ago
and now they very much are have you seen
corporations coming to you guys or is
that more like now it's an
opportunity but not yet there's the
interest we've definitely seen them come
to anchorage yes
so we're actively talking to many of
them and our services again as i
mentioned
we do have the full stack both on on the
infrastructure side and on the services
side
so they can come to anchorage to not
just safekeep but
buy sell finance have pricing
do all sorts of different things and one
of the interesting one of the
interesting aspects here is that capital
preservation is still very much focused
on
bitcoin of course but a lot of the other
businesses are not
anybody that is interested in stable
currencies of course is not talking
about bitcoin
is talking about other platforms like
ethereum and uh anybody that is actually
looking at
these new assets are coming out like
oasis that is about to come out in the
privacy aspects
that that is a totally different
blockchain and so really having someone
like anchorage that supports
hundreds of assets is is something that
is also a unique differentiator
towards some of the other large players
absolutely
last thing i want to talk about is uh
decentralized finance i think that um
you know if you look at bitcoin as kind
of an application of decentralized
finance or decentralized money
there's now this um entirely new
industry that's being built
uh everything from uh decentralized
exchanges to lending mechanisms etc
you guys are embracing a lot of that and
kind of empowering it
how do you think about the balance
between centralization
from the company versus the
decentralized
component of some of this and do you
kind of see uh
some transitions back and forth or just
how do you think about decentralized
finance and what you guys are doing
today
yeah i don't think these things are at
odds at all people point out that
how can anchorage participate in a
decentralized finance if we're a
centralized company that is aggregating
assets of clients
so i don't actually i think the better
way of thinking about anchorage
is specialization if you are a large
company
you do not have the ability to recruit
the talent you don't have the background
you don't have the ability or
really want to spend the time building
an infrastructure that supports
hundreds of different assets that is a
qualified custodian that has insurance
that has
all of these services on top you you're
not going to spend that money
and that's how companies do these things
right they specialize or
either either specialize in their own
area or they take somebody out from the
market that specializes in that and can
offer it more
cheaply so that's how i see it it
doesn't really matter um
that it's decentralized or centralized
these companies need help
and we're just here to provide help and
of course help is in the form of a
highly specialized company that is
centralized uh but that's just you know
it's not that we're centralizing in that
we're at odds with decentralization
is that we are a specialized company
that does what we do
digital asset platforms for institutions
really really really well and so that
doesn't mean that we can't
interact with d5 and in fact
institutions
through anchorage can interact with ify
and do in many different ways
for example governance decisions on
maker governance decisions on sello
they vote directly through anchorage
with the same safety that we have for
their assets so they're actually
impacting
the way in the direction of these
blockchains because they're voting
through anchorage
we're talking about yield opportunities
so we support compound
and people can actually go through
anchorage to try to participate in some
of these
yields farming or these yield generating
opportunities
but at the end of the day if you think
about it anchorage doesn't really care
where you generate your yield in fact
anchorage is here
to pay you and so if the yield
opportunities are in cfi
and it is traditional lending order book
based lending that we can do and
generate the most yields for your
bitcoin
that's fantastic and if it's d5 then
that's fantastic too we could also
generate yield
what we're seeing though is that the
interest for institutions and their
comfort levels
and order book old style lending is a
lot
higher than their comfort level with the
current defy
and smart contract risk and things like
that even though there's already uh
obviously quite a few people
experimenting and especially their
crypto funds that are very much on the
bleeding edge where
all that they do is uh defy lending and
taking advantage of these opportunities
but anchorage really at the end of the
day doesn't care we are here
to allow you access to crypto and d5 is
crypto the same way that stable assets
are crypto the same way that bitcoin is
crypto the same way that
you know i guess uh depending on who you
ask libra is crypto
all of these different things are
different ways of interacting with
blockchain interacting with technology
and anchorage is just a platform that
allows institutions to do it
at the end of the day we do not see we
do not believe that the platform should
dictate
what investors want to invest or do the
platform should support it
i think that's a great way to look at it
before we wrap up i ask everyone the
same two questions and you'll get to ask
me one
the first is what is the most important
book that you've ever read
that's a really hard question so i i
read about
50 books a year okay and
that means that multiplying by the last
few years there's a lot of choice
i don't think i have a good answer i can
tell you the the two books that i read
this year that come to mind
that are the most exciting ones versus
the most important book
um i think the most important book has
been different for me in different
phases of my life
at some point i think a book about
networking was the most important book
for me which right now no actual metrics
so
ethernet networks not not really
anything more than that
um that was the most important book for
me at that specific um
span of time but this year two books
that i really enjoyed
uh one of them on the fantasy side by
brandon sanderson
um the stormlight archive that he's been
writing for over 10 years now
the rhythm of war just came out
yesterday so i just started reading it
so it's top of mind
so i really love brandon sanderson and
then the other book that i reread this
year again
was the electronic value exchange which
is the story of
d-hawk and visa coming into being which
is just you know a fantastic story then
i highly recommend everybody reading
and it's just a beautiful view of how
this problem was solved and how it came
to be so i think both of those are
fantastic
but by and large what i what i do is i
split my reading into
50 fantasy 25 technical books
and 25 percent silicon valley mumbo
jumbo
i love that breakdown 50 fantasy is uh
is a a hefty investment there uh
speaking of fantasy
second question is more fun aliens are
you a believer or a non-believer
i think i'm a believer i have to uh you
know
look at the the statistics and
say that there must be life not how
aliens are portrayed in the movies but
there's definitely extraterrestrial life
out there
i'm sure of that do you think that we
will find them
in our lifetime like come in contact and
confirm
no i don't think so i think those
problems are a lot uh
a lot larger um to to address than i
think people
people foresee them to be couldn't agree
more
uh they're there we just probably are
not going to come in contact
you could ask me one question to uh to
wrap this up what you got for me
well actually i'm gonna turn this around
and say what is
the most impactful book that you've read
because that's a really hard question
yeah oh there we go
i've said it so many times like everyone
knows so rich dad poor dad think and
grow rich
and uh the richest man in babylon were
definitely the three i read them
uh back to back to back when i was like
20 21 years old
uh those were definitely the most
impactful in my life uh i've been trying
to think of like
what is something that uh isn't
necessarily
um a book uh
that's a piece of content that's like
been really impactful
and i gotta say one of the things that
um
it's a classic but really is probably
one of my favorite things on the on the
internet
is uh peter thiel's talk at um i think
it was stanford
or y comedy i think it was at stanford
um all about
uh kind of zero to one the idea that uh
you know competitions for losers
uh build a monopoly all that kind of
stuff um and i think really it's just
it's a completely different way of
thinking right it um
really forced a lot of people to uh
change
their actions and so um yeah the books
are
i talk about them all time but that
piece of content i think is probably
one of the more impactful ones that i
haven't mentioned before
and what percentage of your guests
actually say the bitcoin white paper as
the most
important thing that they've read i
don't know if i've ever had anyone say
it
mainly because i asked for a book so i
think like mentally they're thinking
books
um but uh i actually wonder
what percentage of the guests have read
the bitcoin white paper
right it's definitely not a hundred
percent it's not zero percent
um this is probably bad but like my
guess is that
most people have actually not read the
bitcoin white paper
like more people than we think have not
right
which is like a little sad but uh
you know it's always one of my first
suggestions is like hey you should go
read this you should
you know a couple other pieces of
content but um
on the positive side a lot of them have
it framed on their walls so you know uh
that's also
that is true that is very true um
so we'll we'll see but uh all right
where can we send uh people to find you
on the internet or find out more about
anchorage
yeah anchorage is at anchorage.com it's
the easiest way to get in contact with
us
and as far as i'm concerned on twitter
at diogo monica
awesome man listen this was fantastic
you guys are building an absolute
giant of a business and becoming more
and more important to
the ecosystem every day so thank you so
much for uh for all the hard work that
you guys are doing and we'll have to do
this again in the future
let's do it thank you for having me